تحول تاريخيا في اوروبا يوصف بالزلزال
السياسيه يتمثل في تصدر التحالفات اليمنيه
للحكم في كثير من دول القاره وبرلماناتها
ظاهره غير مالوفه منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مع مثل هذا الصعود
الكبير والسريع لاحزاب من اقصى اليمين لا
تخفي جذورها الفاشيه والنازيه يضرب الطرح
اليمني دوما على وتر التهديد العرقي او
الثقافي من قبل مجموعات تعتبر دخيله على
المجتمع ويتركز خطابه في اوروبا حول رفض
التخلي عن السياده الوطنيه للدول وبالتالي
التحفظ على الوحده الاوروبيه الى جانب
معاهدات الهجره والمهاجرين خصوصا من دور
الجنوب فضلا عن تغذيه الانتماء المسيحي ضد
الانتماءات الدينيه الاخرى المخاوف من
تيارات اقصى اليمين في اوروبا ليست فكريه
او سياسيه فقط ولكنها تتصل بكون بعض تلك
التيارات ينتهي انشطه المسلحه ويقدم على
اعمال عنف واغتيالات استعراض التمدد
المتسارع لليمين الى الخارطه الاوروبيه
يفسر قلق المتخوفين من تاثيراته على
المستقبل القريب للقاره في اكتوبر الماضي
وصلت جورجيا بيلوني زعيمه حزب اخوه
ايطاليا في الجذور القريبه من الفاشيه
لرئاسه الوزراء البلاد للمراه الاولى وفي
الرئاسيات الفرنسيه الاخيره في ابريل
الماضي فازت مرشحه اقصى اليمين ماريل
لوبان رغم خسارتها السباق بنسبه لا يستهان
بها وهي اكثر من 41% ثم حصل حزبها التجمع
الوطني الفرنسيه على 99 مقعدا في انتخابات
الجمعيه الوطنيه لاول مره منذ عام
1986 على مدار السنوات السابقه انتهجت
المانيا سياسه الباب المفتوح امام
اللاجئين لكن تلك السياسه غزت لاحقا حظو
حزب البديل من اجل المانيا اليمني الشعبوي
المعارض للهجره ليومسي عام 2017 ثالث اكبر
حزب في البرلمان الاتحادي الالماني
في ابريل الماضي فاز رئيس الوزراء المجري
فيكتور اوربان بالانتخابات للمره الرابعه
وفي يوليو قال في خطاب له ان الاوروبيين
على استعداد للاختلاط فيما بينهم لكنهم لا
يرغبون ان يصبحوا شعوبا متعدده الاعراق
ادخطاب الاستقاله اقرب مساعدي اوربا ووصف
بالنازلي البحث قبل ان يتهم الصحافه
باساءه تفسيره كلامه وفي سبتمبر الماضي حل
حزب ديمقراطيس السويد من اقصى اليمين في
المركز الثاني في الانتخابات بنسبه 20
ونصف في المئه وحصل على 176 مقعدا وفي
اسبانيا احتل حزب فوكس من اقصى اليمين
المركز الثالث في انتخابات البرلمان اواخر
2019 وحصل على 52 مقعدا من اصل 350 باكثر
من ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون صوت على واقع
ازمات اقتصاديه وسياسيه من ابرزها ملف
انفصال كتالونيا